I was never a political person I come
from a very poor background and I wanted
to make money I wanted to be rich I
didn't want to be poor anymore and you
know the way that I did that was I made
millions of dollars by betting that the
economy would be terrible forever and
that was that was a profoundly
politicizing experience and it has made
me somebody
who is super interested in the economy
and the way the world works and and I
want to give everyone else the
opportunity to come on that Journey that
I went on basically to come into this
space come into this world which is not
normally well explained the world of
Economics the world of finance and and
see the way it really works meet the
people in that world the the crazy
Maniacs that I worked with learn about
it from them like I did and feel what I
felt